大家好 我是學長
歡迎來到學長的咖啡沖煮攻略
那學長有聽到呢
每週次都會更新一些咖啡的知識
以及沖煮的手法
如果各位對精明咖啡有興趣的話呢
歡迎訂閱起來
然後並且打開小鈴鐺以及分享下去
那其實學長跟大家講六個技巧
讓你的咖啡品質馬上可以提升
變更好喝
那都是很簡單的
那首先呢第一個部分呢是洗磨豆機
這個概念呢其實很重要
因為呢一般來說
我們在家裡面沖咖啡
不一定是這麼頻繁的
可能我一天沖一次
甚至有時候你不小心兩天只沖一次
所以你的磨豆機機身裡面可能會卡一些殘粉
有些磨豆機它的設計比較不良
要卡很多的粉
那這個殘粉如果你跟你的新粉混在一起的話
就可能造成一些不好的味道
所以學長建議大家第一個技巧就是
我可以先用個三五顆的豆
不是克 三五顆
所以我只要三五顆的豆
然後先清潔一下
利用新的豆子
清潔一下我的魔豆漆
你也不要覺得會浪費啦
因為真正好的品質才是它之前的部分
可以看花了兩秒鐘的時間
把之前的舊豆推出來以後
把這個粉倒掉
然後你的魔豆漆就是乾淨的了
這個時候你再加入新的豆漆
譬如說我要20克豆漆
就加入以後再進行研磨
你就可以確保這一把的豆子
不會受到舊豆子的影響你的風味就會比較好我們研磨完畢了那這個豆子就可以確定
它是新鮮的沒有之前的產品
好第二個技巧就是關於濾紙的部分
因為濾杯跟濾紙其實它並不完全是會貼合的
尤其換不同的濾杯的時候
所以我們在摺濾紙的時候
建議大家要想辦法讓它跟我們的濾杯能夠相符合
那一般來說我們是不是要先摺這個綠子邊邊的邊線
摺完以後呢把綠子撐開
放到綠杯的時候呢
千萬要記住先用你的右手把你的綠子往下壓一點
然後呢會看到有個翹翹的部分
這個時候呢再用你的左手把這翹翹的地方往下壓
你會發覺說呢 100%的貼合在我的綠杯上面
這感覺就很舒服
那其實你可以看到我剛剛第一次摺的跟第二次摺
中間有這麼一公分左右的落差
所以如果你沒有做這件事情的話呢
你待會在沖煮過程中
它一定會翹翹的
會影響你的流速
還有會讓你覺得沖煮起來不太舒服
沖煮的舒服也是很重要的
那第三個技巧是關於
落粉的部分
我把我粉倒進去的時候呢
這個時候呢
我的粉面它是不平整的
那不平整會有什麼狀況呢
就是我一給水的情況之下呢
因為不平整的表面會讓我的水
從高處往低處流
在第一時間就直接讓你悶蒸就不均勻了
因為你可能低促的地方會試水比較多
所以我們就可以把濾杯拿起來
稍微搖晃一下
這個搖晃不要未搖而搖
我們盡量要觀察一下說我的所有的粉面它都是在一個水瓶的狀態這樣子你在給水的情況之下你才不會有這種水往低出流的狀況尤其是悶蒸它非常的敏感
如果某個部分呢
它的水給太多的話
是很容易造成萃取過度
然後不好喝的狀況
所以這個技巧也非常重要
第四個技巧是關於
你要沖之前呢
你可能先想一下
或是說稍微記錄一下
我待會要怎麼沖
因為很多人可能不是
那麼鹹熟的情況之下
你沒有稍微記錄一下的話
你充過過程中
你一下子的腦子就亂了
你就充不好
所以建議你用手機也好
用紙筆也好
先寫一下
譬如說我們增40克
待會中心到180
然後後面可能兩次繞圈圈
大概是幾cc
那你在待會充過程中
就有個參考值
你忘了的話可以瞄一點
對你的充足的安全感來說
會好很多
比較不會荒腔走板
一不小心就充失誤了
那第五個技巧呢
是關於一個練習的技巧
好 你可以拿一個下壺
或者拿一個濾杯都可以
你在給水之前呢
你可以先稍微練一下手
為什麼呢
因為每一次我們裝的水位
可能會有點差異
或者說你今天的手還沒有熱
比較卡一點點
你稍微繞一下
感覺一下今天的給水狀態
這個水柱是不是你想要的
這個大小是不是你要的
然後繞的速度
還有繞的手感
你OK不OK
如果覺得OK 繞個二三十CC的水
蠻順的
你就可以準備正式來給水
這個方式可以讓你的給水穩定度
增加非常多
因為非常非常多的人就是真的是很緊張或者說沖煮過程中都沒想一下去就一大堆水讓你的悶蒸整個塌掉的這種狀況很常發生最後一點就是關於你給水的時候
盡量的讓我的手中骨的虎嘴
靠近我的粉面
因為當我的虎嘴離粉面這麼遠的情況之下
我的水會飄
而且可能會讓你的粉塵被推倒
或你的結構會比較不完整
被沖散的狀況
但是如果我把我的壺嘴
盡量靠近我的粉面的話呢
它就有很有可能是比較可以完整的
力道也不會這麼大
所以盡可能靠近了以後
我再來給水
靠近了以後
給水順順的往外繞
不用緊張
這樣子你的粉塵的完整度
就很容易維持到很好的
那以上六個呢
就是一些我們沖煮之前的一些小前置作業
但是這些細節就可以讓你的咖啡
確實比較容易好喝
畢竟魔鬼藏在細節裡
如果你的動作老是那麼大手大腳的
你不好喝也是很正常的嘛
所以你還有什麼可以增加咖啡品質的小技術嗎
小技巧嗎 可以跟學長分享一下
今天的咖啡送功能就說到這邊為止
希望大家的過年都可以沖一杯好咖啡囉
OK 我們下次見 掰掰
接下來介紹VV咖啡的合作夥伴
Kafec 是日本咖啡器材專業品牌
招牌快流速的Avaca麻辛維濾
只是許多咖啡師的首選
最近針對戶外需求提出的
Tritan咖啡分享湖
同時兼顧外出的防摔需求
和手沖的使用體驗
讓你的露營不必妥協
詳細資料可參考下方的資訊欄